[MUSIC PLAYING]
All right.
So let's talk about
the Six Epochs.
Ray Kurzweil talks about
the Six Epochs of Evolution
as leading us inexorably towards
a technological singularity,
a crescendo, an orgasm
of cosmic proportion.
He talks about Epoch 1,
physics and chemistry,
information stored
in atomic structures.
We move on then to
Epoch 2, biology,
information stored in DNA.
We then get to Epoch
3, brains, information
stored in neuropatterns.
We then move to
Epoch 4, technology,
information stored in our
tools and software programs.
Then we move to Epoch
5, we're currently
living through today, the merger
of biology and technology,
the extension of our
cognition, the outsourcing
to our technological tools,
the creation of the eye-mind,
the symbiosis between man
and machine that turns us
into something far greater,
which eventually gets us
to Epoch 6, a complete
flourishing of nanotechnology
and biotechnology.
We impregnate the universe
with intelligence.
We merge with all the
matter in the universe.
And the universe
essentially wakes up.
Tell me that that is not
an intoxicating idea.
The kind of idea that inspired
Alan Harrington to say,
in my mind, "having created the
gods, we can turn into them."
[MUSIC PLAYING]